so here you can punch it a bit more oh
my gosh it feels like it is so
responsive this is the new F-150
Lightning an electric version affords
iconic F-150 pickup truck the F-150 has
been the best selling vehicle in America
for about four decades and today facing
increasing competition from both new and
old rivals Ford is looking to the F-150
Lightning to stay ahead of the pack with
so much riding on the success of the
lightning I met the woman who
spearheaded its development it is a
really big risk in a way to Electrify
such an iconic vehicle despite Fierce
competition from other automakers the
F-series has long dominated America's
truck Market but according to Ford many
lightning buyers are new Ford customers
so the next challenge will be convincing
its Die Hard pickup drivers to go
electric to understand what's at stake
for one of the nation's oldest
automakers I took a test drive my myself
oh my gosh accelerates so quickly I feel
like this is too fun to be doing on a
Wednesday afternoon on the highway but
this is a 1980
occurs the mountain with the best gas
mileage and it's built forward jump
Ford introduced its F-series trucks in
1948. since then there have been 14
generations of F-series the F-150 didn't
appear until 1975 as part of the sixth
generation of F-series
today American drivers continue to favor
the F series over its competitors making
the F-150 the most popular vehicle in
the country
earlier this year Ford launched its
first electric pickup the F-150
Lightning this moment is every bit as
important to this company and to this
country
is when the Model T first started
rolling off the assembly line
one of the first things that stood out
to me about the lightning is its
appearance
the design of the lightning is quite
similar in a lot of ways to the original
F-150 tell me about the decision making
around keeping that design sort of
similar so when we were doing some early
discussions with customers it became
very clear to us that we really wanted
to maintain that F-150 DNA in a way from
an appearance perspective one of the
customers told us if my kid was going to
go draw this truck it needs to look like
a truck from the outside the lightning
is roughly the same size shape and
height as other crew cab 4x4s with a
short cargo box particularly with the
box it was something that we wanted to
make sure that we kept literally
identical to our gas truck to be able to
again help that customer transition if
they're bringing accessories right over
from their gas truck into an electric
truck the inside of the lightning will
also be familiar to F-series owners
although the truck features some updated
Tech like the 15.5 inch display screen
available on certain models it's so
quiet I forget that it's on that's one
of the best things about the EV silence
is golden in the race to develop their
EVS automakers had different Visions
Ford prioritized speed by taking its
existing gas powered F-150 and
retrofitting it with battery power Ford
beat GM to Market GM on the other hand
focused on creating an all-new set of
battery cells and Motors that can be
used as a base for future EV models GM
says that building up its platform has
taken more time but the company says
laying this foundation will allow them
to more quickly produce EVS in the
future and your strategy is different
from many of your competitors and that
you started with the F-150 platform and
work from there instead of building a
new platform tell me about that decision
making process the vehicle is actually
completely ground up it's an all new
frame it's an all-new battery all new
Motors all new rear suspensions so
really in a way that underpinning of the
vehicle is completely designed
specifically for this electric truck
what's similar at least from an
appearance perspective is the cab and
the box of the truck but actually the
inside the guts what makes it a truck is
actually completely ground up
since Ford prioritized getting to Market
first the lightning beat most of its
Rivals when it hit dealer Lots this
spring but competition is heating up GM
Silverado EV and Tesla cyber truck are
expected to be released next year in
2024 stalantis is planning to release
its Ram EV
what is the 0 to 60 it's as fast as any
race car 0 to 60 in less than four
seconds
what were your range goals for the
lightning and how did you meet them we
talked to a lot of commercial customers
early on and kind of found that 200
miles is a really good Target for them
for the retail customer the magic number
was really around 300.
the lightning comes with two battery
options a standard range battery which
can go about 240 miles or an extended
Range model which can travel up to 320
miles and can recharge in 41 minutes
some of Ford's competitors are
advertising future models with longer
ranges than the lightning both the Chevy
Silverado EV and the GMC Sierra EV are
expected to have a range of 400 miles
Tesla said its cyber truck will feature
a range between 250 to 500 miles and
rivien said their r1t will likely have a
range between 260 to 400 miles
Ford said it wants to be selling 2
million EVS around the globe each year
by 2026 in August and September the
lightning was one of the quickest Ford
models to move off dealer Lots sitting
on average for just eight days before
being sold we had actually cut off our
reservations last year at about 200 000
units so we're working very quickly
right now
to get our capacity up to a running rate
of 150 000 by the end of next year
although Ford Sales have outpaced its
competitors in recent months the company
has encountered supply chain challenges
most recently Ford experienced a
shortage of its blue oval badges which
has impacted the F-series line even
though Ford has taken an early lead in
the EV race the veteran automaker is not
getting comfortable and has its eye on
the wave of competitors about to hit the
market your Crosstown rival GM has said
if you fast forward a year in the EV
race they're going to be winning because
they've spent more time on their
platforms now where do you think Ford
stands in the long term EV Race part of
what we've tried to do is really take
the Best of Both Worlds from that truck
and taking what already works and then
adding to it some of the new elements
for electrification I do think that we
spent a really good amount of time in
terms of thinking through how we can get
to Market fast we will also be learning
this whole time with this truck out in
terms of how to make the product even
better for our customers so when our
next Generation comes out we'll probably
still be ahead
[Music]